oh the new and improved Sonic is coming
in fast with a fresh look and a new
trailer but the process to get to this
point was a bit of a slow one so did
they get it right on the second try
we're talking about it right now on the
ketchup when the og trailer for the
Sonic the Hedgehog movie was released
back in April the backlash over how
different the character looked was Swift
and loud people weren't really into
Sonics teeth or his legs or his head
size in other words like this user on
Twitter said he looked like a young boy
in a costume meow now we all know people
complain about movie trailers all the
time that's definitely no surprise but
this time the powers that be were
actually hearing what the fans were
saying which is wild not long after the
trailer dropped Sonic's director Jeff
Fowler tweeted thank you for the support
and the criticism the message is loud
and clear you aren't happy with the
design and you want changes it's going
to happen and that was actually really
easy and Sonic's redesign wasn't just a
quick touch-up this was a full-on
makeover about a month later it was
officially announced that the film's
original release date of November 8th
had been pushed back three months to
Valentine's Day 2020 because nothing
says romance like a video game movie no
I can't with that guy so fast-forward
six months and here we are with a new
trailer a new sonic with less teeth and
a new outlook from fans like Matthew on
Facebook who said much much much better
I actually made it through the whole
trailer this time and Joshua who wrote
way better creepiness averted and some
peeps on Twitter agreed with comments
like look at what they did with my boy
Sonic I love him and it's honestly
insane even looking at the old Sonic
design it doesn't even feel real anymore
it's like we all collectively had a
nightmare and then of course there's my
personal favorite comment this is the
reason I never rushed a girl when she's
doing her makeup issuance is key I mean
one eyebrow can take 20 minutes to fill
in and fans like van on Facebook are
also quite happy and surprised because
it's probably the first time in history
the studio heard the fans voice and then
of course there's the conspiracy
theorists like this sort of user who
said I officially stand by the
conspiracy that the horrible designed
was simply the greatest advertising
campaign of all time and we just really
argue with that one yeah right it was
lame gift shop was cool though and let's
be real fans are still excited that the
movie stars Jim Carrey James Marsden and
Ben Schwartz as the voice of Sonic and
considering people behind the scenes are
bringing credits for movies like fast
and furious and Deadpool on top of the
fact that the look of Sonic has been
figured out it looks like the film is
ready to take off just if we get out of
here yeah time to go but it's time for
us to kick it over to you now does the
new Sonic make you excited for the movie
and did it change your thoughts on
checking out the film let us know your
thoughts in the comments section and for
more movie news head on over to Ryan
Tomatoes calm and good news our first
book rotten movies we love is out right
now it celebrates 101 movies that are
coming in green but definitely worth
checking out anyway as always thanks for
watching the ketchup if you liked this
episode and you want to see more
subscribe and click that Bell icon
I'm not pres and we'll see you guys next
time
[Music]